[Aplausos]
[Música]
Bienvenidos a diario del mundial el
programa de France 24 donde actualizamos
y analizamos el día a día de la Copa
Mundial de la FIFA Qatar 2022 a
continuación nuestros titulares
Argentina pasa y el u del Duelo con
Francia escalón y sale con variantes y
son estas las que definen el 2-0 sobre
Polonia que deja la Luis Celeste como
líder del grupo de tenemos reportes de
sedoja y también desde Buenos Aires
México se despide derrota Arabia Saudita
pero el promedio de goles se termina la
salida del Tri en primera ronda tenemos
análisis
Francia prueba su suplentes pero pierde
en su último partido contra túnez de
todos modos queda al frente en su grupo
hay relato desde
[Música]
doha para analizar el acontecer de cada
jornada Contamos con la presencia de
Octavio Paz o periodista de la emisora
Blu radio acá en Colombia bienvenido
Octavio Hola Omar un gusto saludarte y
por supuesto también le damos la
bienvenida a nuestro enviado especial
Juan pupiales quien nos trae todos los
detalles de primera mano de esta jornada
en Qatar saludos Juan
Omar Octavio toda la audiencia un saludo
un día más en este mundial de Qatar 2022
Argentina concretó El Milagro una albi
Celeste y reconocible perdió ante Arabia
Saudita en su Debut quedó obligada a dos
victorias para avanzar y eludir el vuelo
El Duelo con Francia en octavos de final
la tarea se hizo hoy aparecieron
variantes en la alineación que superó
2-0 Apolonia y esas variantes
precisamente hicieron la diferencia Juan
Quién nos puede contar de ese partido
sobre todo esos cuatro cambios respecto
al partido contra contra México con esa
primera titularidad para Julián Álvarez
El delantero del Manchester City sin
duda uno de los mejores arietes que hay
hoy por hoy en Europa y hoy cumplió en
este Duelo crucial para los argentinos
también esa titularidad de Enzo
Fernández el jugador del benfica que
cumplió en esa Victoria contra México
así como el regreso del Romero y la
inclusión El regreso también de nahuel
Molina por la banda derecha un partido
que se mostraba complicado para los
argentinos en esta primera parte de
Polonia que saltó al campo demasiado
conservadora Milly ni siquiera jugó un
solo minuto tuvieron solamente a dos
delanteros en el campo que en realidad
era solamente uno Robert lewandowski que
se peleaba contra el mundo buscando
cualquier pelota que le pudiera llegar
el plan de Polonia parecía que podía
funcionar en esos primeros 45 minutos en
los que vimos ese penalti desperdiciado
por Lionel Messi penalti cometido por el
portero polaco Forge y que fue muy
polémico después de lo visto en la
repetición y que aún así fue ratificado
por el bar pero para la segunda parte en
esos segundos 45 minutos si vimos quizás
algunas de los argumentos por los que
Argentina es favorita el título vimos el
juego de la escaloneta vimos el toque de
Rodrigo de palmos a Messi siendo un
verdadero armador y vimos esa digamos a
Juliana Álvarez acomodarse en este
equipo al 9 del Manchester del
Manchester City llegó ese primer tanto
lo hizo Alexis mahalister y dice
rematando desde en la frontal del área
un centro de nahuel Molina y un golazo
de Julián Álvarez que es una de las
mejores noticias que tiene
escalón y de Cara a esta copa mundo
lautaro Martínez no estaba teniendo una
buena actuación y parece que Julián
aparece ya se acopla un poco el modelo
de juego de este equipo o es lo que
demostró sin duda alguna la mejor
Argentina que hemos visto en esta copa
mundo Argentina que como comentaba hace
Omar comenzó perdiendo contrarresita Y
de qué manera se cambiaron los papeles
Ahora son los que se van para casa y
Argentina la que octavos de final y
además como primera de Grupo Juan esos
cambios que se verificaron el día de hoy
pueden traducirse en cambios en
titularidad para el futuro o sea va a
tener una nueva cara la escaloneta
es un debate importante de lo que tiene
ahora por delante el el director técnico
el Lionel escalón y porque efectivamente
sentar a lautaro Martínez por ejemplo
sentar a una figura muy allegada a Messi
y es sentar a una figura de las entrañas
de escalón y Pero Julián Álvarez
demostró y que está listo para jugar al
lado de Lionel Messi en la delantera en
su Fernández Yo creo que ya va a ser
inti titular indiscutible para este
equipo que juega yo creo que mejor con
él cuando está acompañado de Rodrigo de
Paul Rodrigo de porque hoy por cierto
vimos también unos segundos 45 minutos
quizás también su mejor papel en esta
copa mundo en la defensa yo creo también
que el cutie romero se recuperó después
de las falencias que demostró en esa
derrota contra Arabia Saudita en ese
primer gol de los audios que supuso el
empate el culto y Romero hoy tuvo un
buen papel peleándose contra lewandowski
y yo creo que la pareja de Central está
me queda definida con otamendi y con
Romero para esos octavos de final contra
Australia tiene muchas variantes
Igualmente escalón en eh A partir del
centro del campo en adelante pero este
equipo sin duda alguna es el que hasta
ahora Deja las mejores sensaciones y el
mejor el mejor nivel y Deja los mejores
argumentos por los que Argentina podría
verdaderamente ser una favorita el
título Juan
y cuatro también está en Buenos Aires
Desde allí natalio cosoy nos trajo la
reacción de los aficionados
así celebran los hinchas en esta esquina
en la ciudad de Buenos Aires El Triunfo
de la selección comandada por Lionel
escaloni un triunfo contundente que les
dio tranquilidad la actitud los polacos
muy atrás había que hacer un gol más
para dejarla afuera se me decían que dar
afuera por por que estaba muy atrás no
no Argentina de ir para adelante
me gustó el equipo con actitud yendo
para adelante
y que se llama así que que avanza
Argentina con mucha confianza para
Argentina es lo que hay que tener fe
mucha fe y bien
Además con esta victoria de Argentina se
garantiza el primer lugar de su grupo y
por lo tanto para enfrentar en octavos
de final a la selección de Australia que
los papeles es un rival relativamente
sencillo relativamente fácil y da la
esperanza de lo mejor poder seguir
avanzando en este campeonato llegar a la
final Y por qué no que argentina se hace
con su tercera copa del mundo
en el otro partido del día México superó
dos a uno ahora vaya Saudita para el
resultado no le bastó para avanzar
porque la diferencia de goles en el
grupo se favoreció a Polonia a pesar de
su revés de hoy dos tantos a favor para
y dos en contra para los europeos y dos
anotados y tres recibidos para Los
manitos Octavio una nueva decepción para
México urge una renovación en esta
selección o definitivamente este es el
techo Este es el tope del nivel del
fútbol mexicano sí Lamentablemente Omar
hoy le pasó factura el hecho de no
haberle podido ganar a Polonia porque en
los papeles uno entendía que México
podía perder con Argentina siendo un río
al inferior pero Apolonia tenía que
haberle ganado Polonia hoy demostró que
tiene muy poco fútbol para continuar en
el mundial y México por su lado demostró
que cuando quiere jugar puede
conseguirlo incluso pudo haber marcado
más goles en el partido frente a Arabia
Saudita y no y no lo terminó haciendo
pero lamentablemente Este es el el tope
que hoy México tiene un par de jugadores
por fuera Tecatito Corona que no llegó
por lesión Raúl Jiménez que llegó en muy
malas condiciones y por eso no jugó
desde el arranque pero hoy México al
dejar fuera de la convocatoria a
jugadores como Carlos Vela o Chicharito
Hernández que están brillando en la mls
pero que ya no están según la visión de
martino para estar en este plantel no
tiene de dónde más sacar entonces hay
que esperar que Esta generación de
futbolistas que tiene mucho talento siga
madurando para ver si en el mundial que
van a compartir junto a Canadá y los
Estados Unidos pueden tener un mejor
desempeño hoy tienen una tranquilidad y
es saber que están clasificados El
próximo mundial sin tener que jugar una
eliminatoria y que pueden trabajar en
función de eso
bien Francia enfrentó a túnez con
suplentes y el recambio no pasó el
examen el campeón del mundo sucumbió uno
cero pero igual pasa de primero en su
grupo el relato lo trae de secretar
Natalia Ruiz giraldo
para este tercer y último partido de
fase de grupos de Francia de show
decidió alinear un equipo Beta con nueve
jugadores completamente nuevos sobre el
terreno de juego entre ellos dice así
que por primera vez usaba la camiseta de
Francia e incluso con un Eduardo
camavinga que esta vez hizo las veces de
lateral izquierdo en vez de mantenerse
en el centro como eso su posición normal
y esto se notó bastante en el campo de
juego una Francia que sufrió muchísimo a
lo largo de los primeros 45 minutos
tratando de frenar todas las ofensivas
por parte de túnez un equipo muy bien
parado muy organizado con muchísima
experiencia y esto pagó porque ya al
minuto 58 llegaría el gol después de un
despeje mal despeje de fofana la iduni
recupera la pelota la da a castrid y el
mismo El capitán el número diez es el
encargado de abrir el marcador del único
gol de este partido y dejar con vida a
túnez para los octavos de final
son logró hacer cambios entrar la la
artillería pesada ya con la griezmann
con la radio con mbappé y esto también
se notó sobre el terreno de juego una
Francia que obtenía ya mucho más la
pelota más la creación más incisiva e
incluso griezmann empató el partido ya
sobre los últimos instantes pero fue uno
gol que terminó siendo anulado por estar
fuera del lugar en todo caso al final de
esto ya era en el banquillo de los
tunecinos Las Águilas de Cartago estaban
viendo el partido de lo que estaba
sucediendo entre el Australia y
Dinamarca y cuando ya vieron que era
Australia la que se había quedado con
esa Victoria supieron que el esfuerzo
pues no había sido suficiente y que
quedaban por fuera de este mundial A
pesar de esta Victoria histórica pues
termina siendo una victoria morra amargo
como se puede decir en árabe de esta
manera pues a Francia queda primera de
este grupo de mientras que Australia
queda segunda
Octavio ese partido incluyó polémica por
el gol anulado a Francia y revisado
Aparentemente cuando ya se había
reanudado la acción del partido que
procede en una situación como esa porque
entendemos que que la FIFA va a recibir
un reclamo por parte de la federación
francesa Sí ahí hay dos polémicas la
primera es que la jugada no queda Clara
porque Antoine griezmann Es cierto que
está adelantado cuando sale la pelota
cuando sale el pase pero griezmann no es
el receptor Entonces al cabecear un
jugador tunecino en principio el queda
en segunda jugada puede ser una lectura
de segunda jugada y por eso Y por esa
razón tendría la posibilidad de que
fuese un gol válido es una jugada de
Límite muy pequeño del reglamento y la
segunda la segunda polémica es esa que
el juego se reanudó y luego detuvieron
para ir al bar y en principio eso no se
puede hacer entonces por eso líder de
chance fue muy claro en la rueda de
prensa diciendo que alguien me explique
con el reglamento porque la verdad yo no
lo entiendo No nadie me dijo claramente
que fue lo que pasó él dice que le
preguntó gratuito y tampoco supieron
explicarles y entonces evidentemente no
quedó para nadie Clara la situación
Lamentablemente ya no va a proceder en
ningún reclamo sobre todo porque no
tiene ninguna incidencia en los puntos
por eso es que me parece incluso que la
decisión de The champs de jugar con
suplente fue entre comillas inteligente
porque al saber que no había manera de
que ellos quedaran Al menos que pasara
una catástrofe deportiva pero al saber
que no iba a pasar eso eh Francia
descansó un poco también a sus titulares
en función de lo que va a venir de aquí
en adelante que ya es mucho más
complicado que se puede rescatar de de
esa alineación completamente novedosa
que que mostró hoy de champs primero lo
que decía Natalia darle la posibilidad
de algunos jugadores que ni siquiera
habían debutado con la selección
francesa y no hay mejor escenario para
debutar que una copa del mundo que se
puedan quitar ese lastre ese miedo ese
miedo escénico esos nervios de jugar con
la selección campeona del mundo y luego
darle rodaje a jugadores que normalmente
no lo van a tener Jordan beretude Por
ejemplo en la mitad de la cancha es
decir algunos jugadores que salvo alguna
decisión técnica no tienen espacio y lo
otro es que jugadores como Swami o
camavinha que son mucho más jóvenes que
queríamos pueden jugar muchos partidos
de manera corrida tengan ese rodaje para
llegar a los octavos de final mucho más
aceitados todos liderados por Rafael
barrán que fue el capitán del partido de
hoy Entonces yo creo que más allá del
resultado es cierto Francia perdió y se
vio superada en el primer tiempo muy
ampliamente yo creo que no es una
catástrofe lo que pasó y seguramente de
Jam sacará Un resultado en limpio como
para darle rodaje también a los
jugadores que llegó a la copa el día se
completó con La decepción de Dinamarca
que fue derrotada por Australia con lo
que queda de última en el grupo de con
un solo punto producto desde el empate
que tuvo ante túnez la sorpresa la dan
los oceánicos Australia con la
clasificación Juan estaba para más esta
selección de Dinamarca o se les fue
sobre dimensionada que nos puede
comentar de ese partido
una selección con jugadores como
Cristian ericen que volvía a estar en un
nivel Bueno un buen nivel de juego
christense en Cáceres Michael Cornelio y
sus jugadores con un buen rodaje en las
principales ligas de Europa que terminen
como últimas de grupo con un solo punto
es una decepción además teniendo en
cuenta que Dinamarca se metió en esta
Copa Copa del Mundo como una de las seis
selecciones de Europa clasificadas de
manera directa a esta copa venían además
de la liga de Naciones de ganar en dos
ocasiones a Francia Así que sobre el
papel era una selección llamada hacer
muchísimo más pero se enfrentó a una
selección australiana que dejó muy buen
sabor de boca en esta primera fase que
avanza a la siguiente instancia con los
mismos puntos que Francia y que ha
marcado goles en todos sus partidos sin
duda alguna una decepción danesa que
perdió contra un equipo contra Australia
que venía de clasificar a esta copa
mundo en el repechaje contra Perú y
finalmente son los oceánicos los que
regresan a octavos de final a manera de
antecedentes yo recuerdo muy bien en el
mundial de Alemania 2006 que fue
Australia también consigo clasificar a
octavos de final por ese entonces esa
selección hasta australiana dejaba
sensaciones muy parecidas a esta juegan
muy buenas al fútbol tienen un equipo
muy físico En esa ocasión en octavos de
final perdieron contra Italia con un
polémico penalty invitado a Fabio grosso
y que cobró Todo para que los las
churras avanzara a cuartos de final
ahora Australia se medirá contra
Argentina en un duelo que seguramente
Será muy atractivo Juan lo dejamos para
que descanse ha sido un día largo Mañana
nos reencontramos
y Octavio le pregunto sobre esta
selección australiana que que podemos
destacar que se sabe del fútbol de
Australia que que no solo quedan las
antípodas del mundo Pero además en las
antípodas del mundo futbolístico No sí
Juan es mucho más joven que nosotros y
Su recuerdo se va al 2000 al 2006 el mío
se va al año 93 cuando Colombia le ganó
5 a 0 Argentina Argentina tuvo que ir al
repechaje con Australia y fue
precisamente en esa historia en la que
Diego Maradona volvió a la selección
para jugar el el 94 el Mundial del 94
por eso se van a reencontrar dos equipos
que que se conocieron En aquel momento
pero el tema de Australia primero que
controla la gente de umar que Australia
juega en una confederación distinta a la
suya por esa razón terminó jugando un un
repechaje no juega más en la
confederación oceánica Por esa razón no
se clasifica automáticamente y lo otro
es que jugó la mayoría de sus partidos
de la eliminatoria en doha eran
prácticamente locales ahí por esa razón
Australia se siente muy cómodo en ese
lugar no es casualidad que Australia
haya conseguido seis puntos sentido como
en un lugar que ya conocía conocía los
escenarios los estadios el clima y todo
lo demás y lo otro es que es un equipo
que futbolísticamente es muy pobre
digamos es un equipo que físicamente
está muy bien dotado que que digamos
técnicamente están tratando de igualar a
los rivales que que utilizan esa
potencia física para combatir pero que
futbolísticamente está varios escalones
por debajo de algunas elecciones de esta
de esta copa del mundo lo que pasa es
que aprovecharon perfectamente el mal
momento danés que es una catástrofe
ninguno tenía a Dinamarca último de
grupo es más luego las lesiones de
Francia había mucha gente que decía que
Dinamarca iba a ser el primero del grupo
porque le había ganado también a la liga
de Naciones entonces hay que ver cómo
llega Australia acá yo creo que el tope
de Australia está muy cerca de los
octavos de final Y seguramente Argentina
tendrá que aprovechar esta esta
posibilidad que le da al mundial y no
perderla como la hizo frente a Arabia
Saudita Octavio Muchísimas gracias por
su aporte la seguimos mañana no la
encontramos mañana
y ahora vamos con una selección de
noticias de esta Copa del Mundo
exonerante su nacimiento el rey Pelé se
encuentra estable luego de haber sido
internado esta mañana para reevaluar el
tratamiento para el cáncer de colon que
sufre desde hace poco hace un año las
autoridades del hospital de San Pablo
donde se encuentra ingresado emitieron
un comunicado descartando las
necesidades someterlo a cuidados
intensivos
comienzan los rumores sobre el futuro de
Cristiano Ronaldo que quedó desvinculado
del Manchester United al inicio del
mundial de acuerdo con el diario español
marca el equipo al nacer de fútbol de
Arabia Saudita hizo una oferta de 200
millones de euros por temporada
Estados Unidos no cuenta con el goleador
del partido de Irán Cristian public City
para los octavos de final contra Países
Bajos al menos no por ahora al jugador
del Chelsea le diagnosticaron una
contusión pélvica por el golpe sufrido
en la acción de su gol y será evaluado
día a día para definir su regreso
y antes de irnos repasamos rápidamente
la jornada de mañana en el mundial
España Busca ante Japón quedar fuera en
las quedar en la cima del grupo e y
Alemania está obligada a la victoria
ante Costa Rica en el grupo F Bélgica se
mide al líder Croacia en su última
oportunidad de evitar la debacle
Marruecos tratará de sellar la
clasificación ante Canadá
hasta aquí Diario del mundial los
invitamos a acompañarnos de nuevo mañana
y a seguir con la programación de France
[Música]